you were being booed people were like
getting out of here
because people want to learn about
property you didn't pick that up on the
show you edited the footage and then
when you left people were cheering with
joy that we could just get back to doing
deals and learning about property what I
wasn't that reporting on Joe
let me know hey what's up my name's
Samuel lives I'm a property investor I
help a lot of people make money in
property by teaching what I know and I
also make a lot of money in property
myself and in this video I'm gonna do
something that I don't normally do I'm
going to address some of the things that
have been made up about me
the thing is when you get haters and
critics I always take the moral high
ground and just think I'm gonna let my
results speak for themselves what I've
realized is sometimes when you say
nothing's people just make stuff up and
then when they make stuff up that gets
Chinese whispered and exaggerated and
then people even end up saying crazy
things like Joel is't did on the TV on
Friday like I challenged a brazen
get-rich-quick scammer that I am running
a get-rich-quick scam so let's take a
little look at that and look at what
Joel Isis said he said I'm running a
get-rich-quick scheme because I sell
expensive information there's free
elsewhere
Samuel leads ask people for thousands of
pounds and in return or you get a fax
you can easily find elsewhere for free
no one should be allowed to get away
with that he said that I have load of
bad reviews and he said that I'd
pressure sell and that's why I'm a
get-rich-quick scammer however we've
heard that when you get there you're
actually pressure sold into paying
thousands of pounds for a bunch of
Samuel leads other courses we spoken to
people who paid thousands to attend
those courses and what they got was not
what they were promised so let's look at
that first we get rich quick you've
probably watched my videos hopefully
you've been watching my videos for a
long time I've got over 700 videos on
YouTube I've run the crash course have
you heard me talking about getting rich
quick or have you heard me talking about
becoming financially free over a period
of time I don't believe I teach people
how to get rich quick
Joel Ison said he doesn't know what
financially free means Samuels main gig
is teaching the world how to become
financially free it's not a concept I've
heard of before Joe financially free me
when your passive income covers your
expenses your living expenses so you
don't have to work it doesn't mean rich
I've done it myself
Samuel Leeds 27 he's become a
multi-millionaire through investing in
property everything I teach you stuff
that I've done myself my students have
done it I've got hundreds of students
they've become financially free so
everything I'm teaching works anyway
what else selling expensive information
is available for free elsewhere and ask
people for thousands of pounds in return
for facts you can easily find elsewhere
without paying a penny I don't sell
expensive information I sell training I
give all information now that I can for
free I do that on you to buy a books I
have the crash course which is free I
give all the information and then people
that want training and the difference
between information and training is the
difference between reading a theory book
of how to drive a car and getting in
with a driving instructor so that's the
difference anyone that's done my paid
training will know that actually not
only is it awesome but it's very
different you're getting information
online for free for Starr it's only
available online for free because I put
it online for free if you want to learn
about how to be a doctor or anything you
could say well you can learn it online
for free you can learn it online for
free but also to say that you can't
train because you can find it online for
free you could apply that to everything
does that mean that you people that
teach you how to speak French shouldn't
be able to charge for that because you
can learn to do it online
what about Harvard University that teach
business continuity online should every
private school be closed down should
every University be closed down because
everything's available online for free
it is we did kill us it's week also if
you want to learn something that you're
serious about you're just gonna pay for
the education because if you wanna learn
about property if you type in how to
find your gold mine area how do we go
she ate a property had a you don't just
gonna get the answers for free online
you're gonna get loads of opinions loads
of articles that are gonna be written
from people that aren't financially free
themselves even when you go to
university inland business you're
learning it from someone that's probably
not like me I've done it my trainers
have done it I think it's very valuable
I mean when you come to my training
you're doing it it's a doin ah you're on
the phone to agents as I say it's like
driving a car compared to the theory so
that's my answer to that next bad review
she says that all my customers may be
bad reviews and he proved this by
flashing some bad reviews online every
company that has lots of customers has
bad reviews
why myself have bad reviews some of them
are very legitimate and genuine some of
them are not but I have bad reviews if
unless you have two customers if you
have two students and they're both happy
then you have a hundred percent
satisfaction rate congratulations like
me if you have thousands of customers
I've had over 20,000 people come to the
crash course some of them aren't going
to be happy and they can only bad
reviews of the of the thousands of
people have done my advanced training
some of them are not going to be happy
and some of that might be legitimate we
do you have genuine people that have
been unhappy and we've tried to work
with them and it's it's been our fault
because we've had sloppy customer
service we've had because we grew so big
so fast 18 months ago we went from
having a hundred people to come into our
events to having a thousand plus and it
was just crazy and because of that we
dropped the ball at times the training
was still really really good but the
customer service and someone as we moved
offices we moved to London so we have
got some genuine bad reviews but we've
also got way more good reviews because
what we do works so to say this business
has got bad reviews therefore it's a
scam no let's just look at the reviews
overall and also let me just say this I
have to say this most of the bad reviews
that you see about me or about my
company online often people that never
paid a penny they're from people that
didn't do the training maybe they did
the training and they didn't like it
fair enough maybe they did the training
and it didn't work for them because they
didn't put the time in and they and they
just say all the training didn't make me
rich ok ok but most of the bad reviews
are from people that watch the YouTube
videos didn't like me as a person and
left the bad with you and if you look at
the reviews you can see that yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so don't look at what the reviews are
saying look at what people are saying
that have actually done the training
most of the reviews are actually reviews
of a review even and you might think
whatever Samuel Joe who did a whole show
about me which is one long bad review he
didn't do any of the actual and paid for
training that's the exact same for those
people doing what I believe you should
do is you should just at least do it
before you make before you start making
assumptions and even reviews but even
saying that if you look at the reviews
if you look at Google reviews I think
it's out of nine hundred odd reviews
overall it's four and a half stars when
when you change out to the crash course
when I was teaching property and you
suddenly pulled cameras and tried to
talk to me and I said let's book an
appointment I'd love to chat by the way
let's still do that let's meet and let's
have a discussion I'd love to do that
but I know you won't do that but when
you came you were being booed people
were like getting out of here because
people want to learn about property you
don't pick that up on the show you edit
the footage and then when you left
people were cheering with joy that we
could just get back to doing deals and
learning about property what I wasn't
that reporting on Joe let me know Joe
you said with your friend I don't
remember a name who was apparently a
property expert that finding property
deals on Rightmove was not it was stupid
like oh it's not that it's a secret as
if I was giving bad advice
Samuel Leeds tells you how to source
deals by using the website right move
calm right so he points you in the
direction of the country's biggest
property portal it gets a hundred and
thirty five million visits a month so
it's not exactly top-secret this is what
James Armstrong says about finding
properties on Rightmove when I like
James he was nineteen years old he did
my advanced training he's now
financially free he was nineteen year
old with nothing here's what he says in
response to Joel I said show anyone else
love hearing that it's impossible to
make money selling deals that are on
rightness since july 2019 deals from
right move taking into account refunds
have made me two hundred and seven
thousand pounds deal sourcing is
definitely not dead and right move is by
far the best place to find deals forget
the BS if you want to make money selling
deals
educate yourself and what a great deal
is how to find people who want to invest
and go ahead and get paid Samuel may
sound too good to be true but bank
transfers don't lie and it's the
training that got me where I am today
come on Joe you get like all these all
these nameless people with their blurred
faces that say stuff and say apparently
someone once said all over with food my
undercover operatives rich
hello Starshine he's gonna go on one of
Samuel needs free two-day property
courses Richmond up with colleague Emma
and headed for a hotel conference center
we've bled their faces because they
killed a guy in Cuba
what did Samuel Leeds team make of my
undercover cheer oh well here they are
represented by dolls for illustrative
purposes I've got real people but a real
customers these are real people let me
read this I have had so many people that
have reached out to me and that have
posted publicly about the Joel is't show
and it's just absolutely crazy the
people that have actually done the
training okay so we've got Joseph says
keep up the good work Samuel you must be
really hard to take on so much hate but
you're coping with it like a boss thank
you so many people make money from
Samuels liens his students YouTube
followers and now even hating on Samuels
becoming a business and it's getting
ridiculous love and support but this guy
Joseph he did my training he paid me
1995 pound and now he's doing multiple
deals a month and every time he does a
deal he's making the investment back
that's a good return on investment
that's an actual customer not what you
Joe that's an actual customer that can
give me a truthful opinion
Darren Andrews Darren Andrew says I
physically don't all of Samuels training
let's see how he's getting on I Drive an
Audi r8 I've got 100,000 pound Jaguar
e-type in the Gary I own six apartments
two houses and our tea shops
I had investors literally ready to go on
projects and we've just secured an
option on a parcel of land which will
make me 500 thousand pounds that's half
a million it's just I quit my job a year
ago and I'm living life as long as you
in the same position as me after
actually doing all of the training and
giving it 100% then you cannot comment
this guy Darren Thank You Darren Andrews
like he's done it Andrea Harbour
responded to down and said likewise
Judah Samuels training advice I am now
living in a big
house beautiful surroundings and a
Boston great houses earning good monthly
cash flow building my business and
growing everyday she's financially free
what Joe why didn't you report on this
why did you just pull like 5 or 10 bad
reviews from online and say his
customers aren't happy they are happy we
read the comments I mean Aaron Mathai
was said he was so upset with Joe's poor
reporting and the poor quality of
journalism he said what Joe Lycett got
wrong about Samuel Leeds it did a whole
article about it and guess what it's
getting a lot of traction why because
it's logical and people can see the fake
news that the media and that Joe Lycett
are actually be trained tender I agreed
everyone agreed these are people that
have done it
my first lease option contract terms
agreement hopeful time today keys on
Monday 365 you know how much 365 is
Samuel 365 95 can a month and she
getting the keys to a deal on Monday
least option agreement that mean she
probably didn't pay anything for the
house I'll do a whole nother video on
what a lease option agreement is another
time and there's just so many David and
well said assignment for Samuel 365
soars over eight twenty percent below
market failures in the past three weeks
in the process of completing on the
purchase of a buy-to-let with potential
HML I'm on fire
we're doing deals like this you just got
a look at the return on investment is it
worth paying for training or not this is
what my customers are actually saying so
you can listen to the faint news or you
can just look at what people are
actually saying I'm the Austin I mean
this could get boring couldn't it this
could get really boring almost as boring
as Joe Lycett show where he's bringing
up all these all these faint news
stories I'm Samuel Leeds Academy member
see if someone says I'm the Samuel Nizza
cut in about all months hanging with 365
oh but okay oh listen but if they're
just giving a review of a review what
does it business a and before my first
session it was brought to my attention
all the negativity placed media around
him I was worried about being scammed
but I can honestly say now I feel so
silly the support from the Academy is
second to none they pump out so much
valuable content on such a regular basis
and the networking that comes with the
course as well as the constant advice
from the trainers is amazing hope you're
keeping whilst I'm your lives like this
is what people are saying okay this was
interesting this dude
and Harris was there at the crash course
the day that Joe came to gatecrash the
crash course with his fate TV cameras
trying to create a story with an agenda
this is what he said
I was there that day in Bristol he was
there let's see what he said and like I
said afterwards we were all still there
you what you do is amazing helping
people develop themselves in a multiple
of ways major plus is I featured in this
unfortunately my face was blurred then
they're saying actually I did the
training it is amazing do you know this
let me give you a stack because you
might say Joe got the bad testimonials
Samuel got the good let me give you the
actual stats the stats to this 93% of
our advanced students people that paid
us 93% rated us between a 7 and a 10 out
of 10 that's pretty good is everybody
over the moon no there's some people
that aren't happy but only a few only
like any business I'm proud of my
results I'm proud of my training stop
spreading fake news thank you to the
people that are standing up about this
crazy witch hunt and the saying actually
I've done it and this is what's going on
thank you to the people that are coming
on winners Wednesday it's time to
actually let all this nonsense stop and
speak truth and listen you say Joe that
I pressure sale people yeah
[Music]
what's going on here is an aggressive
form of pressure selling they're
artificially creating a hugely pressured
intense atmosphere like Eamonn Holmes
does when he enters a room these
techniques are outlawed under Section 7
of the consumer protection from unfair
trading regulations I sell my courses
I'm a businessman and I sell my stuff I
sell my pound products I sell my 95
pound product I sell my 10,000 pound
products because I believe that they
work based on the feedback that I get
and based on what I did
I only shamed meself but don't say that
I precious out on it on the scam because
it's frankly not true
pressure selling is illegal if I was
precious standing I would be stopped all
this nonsense is just ridiculous you say
that I get people into a room create an
environment that makes them as if
they're idiots Joe you might think that
you're your audience idiots I don't
think my audience are idiots your
audience might watch you like this just
believe everything that the TV says and
sit like a sheep my audience is smart
and they don't do that
so stop spreading lies my only audience
make up their own mind my people come to
the crash course they might be skeptical
but they're smart they listen to what I
have to say and they make up their own
mind and the reason that I get the
energy high is because people are
excited and I want people to be awake so
that they can phone deals and make money
from estate agents stop spreading fake
news and also let me say this I haven't
ran any events the last three months
because the lockdown but more people
have been doing the crash course than
ever before over 2,000 people have done
the online crash course and many of
those have gone on to be further paid
training and the feedback has been
phenomenal how can I pressure sell them
when they're in the comfort of their own
home using the logic of their brain my
audience I'm not stupid and that's why
I'm saying this listen number one Joe
let's meet and have a conversation about
these allegations you said you spent
three months trying to find mate
we have been tracking this guy for
and this is our one chance to get in and
so I'm super nervous but super thrilled
that he's here Here I am I'm not hiding
I'm gonna do another video as well Joe
about actually what you did behind the
scenes that no one knows we're gonna I'm
gonna do a bit of an expose on Joe
Lycett which will be coming soon and I'm
gonna give the full story I'm also gonna
do a video on Lord Sugar
and some of the other crazy stuff that
are going around which is just
ridiculous
Lord Sugar got so angry and that's not
something you imagine happens literally
every day that he even sent us a little
video I don't know Samuel Leeds I met
him briefly at a conference a few years
ago any claims that I have given him
business advice and meant at him are
pure fantasy and completely untrue and I
set the record straight and I'm excited
so subscribe but listen number one Joe
let's meet let's chat number two guys if
you're watching this make up your own
mind don't be don't believe me don't
believe Joe don't take my word for it
don't believe anyone pay one pound one
pound to do the full crash course get
coaching get mentoring for seven days
that's my offer for seven days get the
coach and get the training get the crash
course for one pound and at the end of
that week decide what you think make up
your own mind and if you want to go
further awesome if not awesome you want
to do the free stuff awesome you wander
the page stuff awesome but let's stop
this stupid witch hunt and this nonsense
and I'm looking forward to do more
videos subscribe smash the like button
real soon is going to be the Lord Sugar
video and Joe Lycett I've got your back
buddy Channel four serious thank you for
the publicity
[Music]
protecting me
[Music]